[Música]
[Aplausos]
primero tras el baño
hoy los invito a nada conmigo quiero
participar con ustedes nado que de
alguna manera ha tenido mucho
significado en mi vida y no solamente
participando sino invitarlos a que
acompañen a que logramos juntos este
camino
a que cada uno de ustedes pueda
participar
[Música]
de alguna manera tiene
no lo hagáis es una isla más conocida
como el contrario de cavar aquella isla
que llevaban a todas las personas que
tenían en su poder hemos dado a la negra
pero posteriormente aquellas personas
que estaban enfermos
aquellas personas quería de alguna forma
no tenía esperanza de vida
el lado de molokai se hace de esta isla
a la isla junto y guapo significa vida
edición y algunas que no quieren amar
cada uno de los días de su vida hacia la
vida la bendición y norman el día de hoy
los invito a es a que todos podamos
verdad cada día de nuestra vida
se la vida en la bendición y la organza
y el nuevo empieza en una tabla en una
tarde como la de hoy en una tarde con
una luz especial con
un mar con un color azul espectacular
[Música]
con mucha ilusión con muchos sueños
que voy a dejar atrás
todo aquello que significamos locales
vivir todo aquello que puede significar
tristeza deterioro enfermedad
muerte para nadar hacia la vida la
bendición y regresar con esta
maravillosa luz de la tarde
pues así de alguna forma empezamos a las
brazadas y muy pronto caigamos
y lograron de la noche
viene a la mente aquello que nos
atemoriza
que de alguna forma nos quita la
concentración que nos hace pensar que no
vamos a poder llegar a nuestro tiempo
sin nada toda la noche y durante la
noche
bien no solamente a la mente aquellas
cosas que de alguna forma nos podrían
hacer
también vienen estas criaturas físicas
que se llaman agua malas que pica típica
muy fuerte y no las ves y te molesta y
cada vez que te te pica una [ __ ]
tienes un actor muy especial y vas
nadando durante toda la noche guía
únicamente por una pequeña luz por el
faro
el punto donde la el punto de nuestra
ciudad
el punto hacia la vida de bendición y la
abundancia
y cuando finalmente amanece después de
nadar toda la noche 12 horas después de
haber empezado ha esperado
yo pienso que ella
ya voy a poder ver las afamadas en un
momento hacer
el punto de que de alguna forma ya no
está mareada durante la noche estuve muy
mareada lo único que podía ver con un
punto fijo
era aquella necesita del pago que se
prenden se apagaba el kayak que venía
acompañándome en a mi lado me generaba
el movimiento estaba en movimiento
constante la luz exiliada en inglés me
marea cuando amanece dije ya pasó la
pero tampoco el mar sigue picado el mar
sigue siendo porque es el mar el cielo
maravilloso
pero al menos ese amanecer me indica que
estoy cada vez más cerca del objetivo
incluso puedo ver la isla puedo ver esta
isla guaje que sin mis calidad de visión
y hablarse en un mirador es a ella
no tengo a mi lista michelle acá y
probablemente me tardé en llegar unas 34
horas
cuando aparecen los primeros rayos de
sol durante este amanecer escuchó un
grito maría y un tiburón maría libro
y entonces la película de mi vida en paz
en mi mente
my el título es una frase
y que en el momento que escuché caminar
sobre las aguas
y salirme de ese punto necesario
y se dejará atrás todo lo que estaba
no nada más en ese momento
y cuando el kayakista me pregunta qué
pasa por qué no
[Música]
y la respuesta del mayorista me dice no
te distraigas y sigue nadando
como no te distraigas y sigue nadando si
hay un tiburón aquí abajo
y yo creo que es algo que puedo
compartir con ustedes para todos los que
están
no se extrae y sigue nadando
sin embargo la película de mi vida
estaba en ese momento haciendo su efecto
en donde estoy qué significado tiene
este proyecto que se llama los siete
mares donde ya la decana de la mancha
donde ya nadie el canal de la página
donde tuve intento para nadar el
espíritu es jugado en japón y no pude
pero ya nadie en el estrecho de
gibraltar
donde estoy nadando el canal de lo local
y me faltan algunos lados por completar
los siete más me falta el canal de
enorme está para jugar me falta el space
reactivo y qué pasa ese tibio que pasó
por debajo de mí
curioso era un tiburón ceda y hoy se
escribe con cera
es curioso cazador y solitario y de
alguna manera estaba curiosos ya su
curiosidad casi me saca de lado
también
[Música]
y tener sobre todo muy claro una parte
que había sido motivo por el cual
estaban al trabajo una caída unas
medidas muy profundas de dónde vengo
porque estoy nadamos agua porque quiero
nadar hacia la vida la bendición
porque hace unos años hace un par de
años había intentado nadar en japón
y después de todas las tormentas que han
pasado en mi vida
después de estas tormentas emocionales
que de alguna forma es tenido que
alcanzar
en donde tengo dos fallecimientos muy
próximos
por una parte y por otra parte
físicamente en japón método nos domina
una tormenta nada
cuando voy pelando
nuevo que estoy en medio de una tormenta
porque me tomo una tormenta estoy
enojada
tenemos
tengo una parte de mí que está muy muy
enojada porque me tiene que tocar un
monumento para excavar
y cuando recibo la indicación de la
embarcación que debo de tener mi nada y
subir de la embarcación y casera del
nado porque no puedo
veníamos no porque esta no es la primera
vez y por éstas
voy a seguir nadando
y en un mundo mi autoridad me dice no
fue designando te tienes que subir a la
embarcación
no vas a llegar a ningún lado
y estoy con ese coraje sino que más
un par de brazadas en que en ese momento
me dijo mi cabeza
y el fondo del mar
un poco el que ha perdido está la peor
tormenta mucho viento mucho oleaje no
importa y cuando es un mismo mi cabeza
y finalmente reciba la mano
en la embarcación no hay opción no se
puede seguirla
verán
me fue
me caigo porque me doy cuenta que en
esta ocasión como en todas las ocasiones
previas de la vida la tormenta
lo que tienen que hacer
igualada
cuando pasa la tormenta que
probablemente a veces ni siquiera somos
conscientes de que las dos mitades
me queda claro que soy distinta esa
tormenta me gusta decir que esa promesa
regresión que a través de la tormenta
puede seguir dando pasos en frente
pude levantar puede decir yo sigo
adelante
y esa tormenta es lo que me permitió
poderme levantar y decir
sigo
cuando tengas una caída o cuando vayas
atravesar por una tormenta no dejes que
la gravedad
o que la tormenta al efecto
de destruirle sino de fortalecer me
levantan y levantan de pronto levántate
con un objetivo claro de a dónde más
levante
y para que una vez que dé un paso al
frente
uno más y así hasta llegar a todos tus
objetivos a todos tus propósitos
y una vez que me decido que voy a nadar
y estoy aquí
a la mitad del lago de molokai con un
tiburón que está nadando debajo de mí
como un título cuando yo asumía que ya
había pasado lo peor
y recuerdo la frase que me dice el
caraquista
no te extrañas y sigue sigue lavando no
permitas este tema de a leer tus
objetivos
yo voy a compartir con ustedes porque
los peores tiburones no están revelando
que están fuera del agua y los más
complicados tiburones
en nuestra mente
y nos frenan los panalistas nos
atemorizan cada día
y la
a cuenta que tenemos como seres humanos
terceros a un lado
y de continuar con nuestros objetivos es
un privilegio
es un privilegio que podamos conocer es
concientizarlos de los problemas que
tenemos pero también de poder decidir
sabiendo
de seguir hacia adelante de seguir
caminar o de seguir nadando
que ningún título te distraiga de tus
sueños sino que te conduzcan a ellos
siempre
y seguimos nada más seguir nadando para
salir del agua
después de 14 horas con 28 minutos
hoy comparto con ustedes hoy comparto y
además de alguna manera es una
invitación para que todos y cada uno
podamos hablar hacia eso hacia lo que es
crítica colocar la vida está bendición y
la bondad porque cada uno de nosotros
tenemos sobre nuestra cabeza todas las
bendiciones del universo y lo único que
tenemos que hacer es decir sonrientes
y yo adquiero todas estas bendiciones
[Música]
todo lo que significa lo mejor de su
vida está en ti
cualquiera que puedas tener levántame
bastante pronto
sigue dando pasos a seguir
y ponte los objetivos y los sueños más
grandes que puedas imaginar y alguien te
diga es una locura lo que estás pensando
aunque sea una altura antes de irme
porque la capacidad que tenemos de ser
conscientes de que ese sueño se puede
hacer realidad es el primer paso para
hacerlo realidad y una vez que haces
ese sueño en realidad tendrás mucho más
y entonces podemos decir que ningún
tiburón me distrajo de mis sueños
y que además de todas las tormentas no
lo es que tuve que trabajar salir
diferente fortalecido
y hoy
como como es el fondo del mar que como
yo iba nadando y estaba la tormenta de
ávila y sin embargo el fondo de la lista
de paz
y deseo que cada uno de ustedes tengo un
corazón como el corazón del mar
que siempre esté paz no importa que
también estás descentralizado no importa
qué tormenta es atravesar
pero que tu corazón siempre esté en fase
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]